hey how's it going bros my name is fanny
pack today we're playing the best game
of all time it's called Tokyo jungle
let's begin okay all right this
basically animals in Tokyo here we go we
start off as a little [ __ ] but don't
you worry by the end of this video we
will probably still be a [ __ ] but look
how fabulous we are wagon that tail if
you hope to survive do not allow
stronger animals to see you so we are
gonna master the art of self like that
[ __ ] is stronger than me have you
seen my fluff
have you seen it [ __ ] there we go no
one can spot my fluff so for some reason
we need to go to that blue car maybe
it's because my owner is look how cute I
am oh my god what was that
alright look at the stuff he's not
seeing this self it's lazy [ __ ] look
at that dog though like this is all he
does all day just turn left and ride but
like what I swear to god there's
something up something over there I
swear to God I have something over there
I swear to God
I'm free Wow oh my god what physics
Jesus Christ Japanese people excellent
yay told you it was the best game ever
so now we're kittycat I don't see how
this is an upgrade from the pompon but
let's try it out press ok yeah yeah and
you need to eat you have a hunger level
in this game and you need to eat and
[ __ ] and we're gonna eat that cute ass
rabbit
finisher yeah solitude
okay now we're a dog okay we're gonna
take over their territory no big deal
these guys are close but I don't know
why I God okay tell me did you see me
he's confused oh god he called Big Mama
Oh God
goodie ah that's okay finish him dodge
dead miss me [ __ ]
oh damn it feels good to be against okay
now we have Shibuya I've been there
cool oh [ __ ] it's about to get real
Golden Retriever hasn't reached a
sufficient rank to interest her
god damn it can't you clearly see that
she wants me look at this she's she
wants it all right we need a hunt get a
chicken come back and check it Vic lamb
what is this how I eat some chicken what
is it laughs you're begging to be killed
what are you doing come back here how
dare you Bamie we're almost there I'm
gonna tiny little chicken baby oh my god
it's so cute
hey chicken baby are you lost let me
find your mother she's dead
I killed your mama Jesus Christ
this game is bringing out horrible
things inside me okay all right we
ranked up I hope she saw me do that I
hope she saw me like kill that little
chicken hey girl what's up yeah that's
right follow me baby I got your back
follow me no big deal what I did that
you want to eat that I'll leave it in
front of you you like that baby you're
like that inside a chimpanzee mr.
chimpanzee please give us your wisdom
there you go welcome to my career [ __ ]
look at that look at is in the garden
join your partner at your lair to me
come on girl let's go have some fun
in your heart give me all my
stay we'll see
what no no no not Christian Jesus Christ
I went fast what what is best game best
game ever
I'm so excited let's keep playing this
is a lot of fun let's start with the
[ __ ] pom Pomeranian okay we're gonna
start off by making Shibuya my town
Tobias come be my [ __ ] my [ __ ]
nope come back here you're chicken [ __ ]
where are you goofed up yes get in
[ __ ] no no no I did I got back
okay
okay he's dead in Dedham [ __ ]
yes eat it yes Wow
high fire price man that was intense a
present for me
yay a portable bed yes
oh [ __ ] oh my god what am i huh I [ __ ]
up my hand out the [ __ ] from ready and
I gotta get rich yeah you just got
ripped Pomeranian rannian that should be
the soundtrack of this video Hummer up
doesn't matter
oh god yes friends
don't call don't call [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
I [ __ ] him up alright we're gonna have
to run oh god no run Canadian run high
grass yep yep Pomeranian no high grass
no that was so quick oh my god well
that's life and death for you one moment
you could be alive and another moment
would be dead and I think that's an
important message from this video you're
welcome for dropping for me dropping mad
knowledge on you this game was awesome
I really enjoyed it I hope you boys
enjoy playing with me leave a like if
you enjoyed
maybe I'll check out this game some more
I'll see you either way in the next
video stay awesome bros I'm gonna ask
we're gonna grow big Bros I'm like a
Chinese dragon nice Oh God